we have found eight mind-blowing Harry
Potter theories that will make you
rethink everything stay tuned to find
out the truth about Hermione Granger's
parents you've got dirt on your nose by
the way did you know Neville's wand
Neville has 99 problems and a wand is
definitely one of them when we first met
Neville Longbottom in the books he is
described as a totally inept wizard in
fact his family thought he was a squib
for a long time then his uncle launched
him out of a window and Neville bounced
yikes Neville struggles with a lot of
things like remembering his robes and
everything to do with potions and he is
really bad at casting spells but Neville
is amazing at herbology but after book 5
Neville really starts to improve as a
wizard he gets more confidence and his
magical skills improve in the deathly
hallows neville leads the student
resistance at hogwarts against the evil
cairo twins
he fights bravely at the Battle of
Hogwarts and let's not forget that he's
the one that kills Nagini
the final Horcrux so why the sudden
change in Neville this fan theory
suggests that Neville's wand is the
reason for most of his problems
this theory goes all the way back to
2004 from an old I'm grrrrrr post user
soggy toots points out that Neville's
wand was actually his dad's that's right
the wand that he uses belonged to the
hero Aurora Frank Longbottom sure
Neville is insecure but the wand chooses
the wizard right this one chose Frank
not Neville of course Neville would have
trouble casting with this wand Neville's
wand breaks at the battle at the
Department of mysteries in the order of
the Phoenix he gets a new wand
presumably from Ollivanders and this
wand chooses Neville that explains why
he's suddenly way better at magic MARY
POPPINS is a witch we are heading into
crossover territory now the Harry Potter
world is full of amazing witches and
wizards have you ever wondered if some
of your other favorite characters were
actually from the same world there are a
ton of fan theories out there about Mary
Poppins including that she is a Time
Lord from the world of Doctor Who but
reddit user big see big suggests that
Mary Poppins was actually a witch in the
Harry Potter universe and she wasn't
just any witch she was an important
witch who works for the Ministry of
Magic this theory suggests that Mary
Poppins was a
course a ravenclaw after Hogwarts she
got a job at the ministry she was
responsible for investigating
muggle-born witches and wizards and also
introducing them to the world of magic
the evidence is totally there her bag
definitely has an undetectable extension
charm on it just like Hermione's purse
and she teaches the kids to keep their
magic a secret this theory also states
that Bert was a squib which is why he
knew all about magic but couldn't
perform it and then this theory takes a
dark turn
where was Mary Poppins when Harry was
growing up well Mary loved muggles and
muggle-borns she lived with them all the
time after all it is likely that she was
a victim of balda Mort in the first
Wizarding war we know he wanted to get
rid of all muggle-borns sympathizers and
Mary Poppins would definitely have been
outspoken in her support Weasley Wonka
the twins Fred and George Weasley are
fan favorites these two talented wizards
are always up for a good time they
caused a lot of trouble but then they
put their skills to good use they open a
successful joke store called Weasleys
Wizard wheezes there are all sorts of
cool products including candies that can
make you sick enough to get out of class
in fact a lot of their products come in
the form of candies can you think of
another famous magical person who made
candy that's right Willy Wonka Willy
Wonka is totally eccentric he has a
factory in London with weird creatures
the Oompa Loompas in the book Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory
we learned that Willy Wonka is a rags to
riches story what if George Weasley
adopted the persona of Willy Wonka after
Fred died at the Battle of Hogwarts he
would be so sad about losing his twin
that adopting a new life would feel like
a good idea
Willy whereas eccentric clothes and a
top hat the figure outside the Weasleys
store wears a top hat though balloon
puss are similar to house elves
George loses an ear in Deathly Hallows
in Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
Willie tells Charlie he's a bit deaf in
one ear
Willy also gives his store to a muggle
named Charlie George like his father
author loved muggles do you think Willy
Wonka is actually George Weasley
we think there is some really compelling
evidence in this theory King Harry our
final cross
theory requires a bit of knowledge about
authoring legends and this is one long
detailed theory from forum motion
basically this theory suggests that
Harry is actually King Arthur rightful
king of the Britons a lot of this has to
do with hints from JK Rowling that
Gryffindor is a house of royalty the
Weasleys mostly have names of actual
British Kings also in the Harry Potter
world Merlin is a very real person
Harry pulled the Sword of Gryffindor
from a hat so did Neville just like
Arthur pulled a magic sword from a stone
in other authors stories the sword lies
on the bottom of the lake where is the
Sword of Gryffindor in the Deathly
Hallows that's right it's on the bottom
of a lake
Harry defeats a dragon which makes him
the pin dragon that's another name for
King Arthur there is also the fact that
Holly is associated with Kings Harry's
wand is made from Holly also there are a
lot of important cups in Harry Potter
there is the house cup the Quidditch Cup
the Quidditch World Cup the Goblet of
Fire and the Triwizard Cup King Arthur's
best-known story is about the hunts for
another important Cup the Holy Grail
basically this theory suggests that not
only is Harry a direct descendant of
King Arthur but that he is a
reincarnated Arthur the myths always say
King Arthur will return when Britain
needs him most well Harry Potter does
save the world from the worst wizard
ever tell me what exactly is the
function of a rubber duck JK Skeeter if
all these crossover theories are true
then that means one thing the world of
Harry Potter is real we've all wished
that this world is real for a long time
we're convinced our Hogwarts letters got
lost in the mail as you can't convince
us otherwise so if there really are
witches and wizards among us how do we
know so much about them there are plenty
of people out there who think that JK
Rowling is just a pen name for a very
famous witch Rita Skeeter herself both
Rita and JK are blonde and they both
know a lot about this magical world as
an unregistered animagus Rita would know
all the tiny little details that we see
in the books it's generally accepted
that after the Battle of Hogwarts Rita
Skeeter lost her credibility some theory
suggests that she was even banished from
the magical world well how would a
writer make money in a new
world they say writers should write what
they know rita skeeter under the name JK
Rowling wrote about the boy who lived
and marketed it as a fiction to mughals
mughals don't believe it's real so she's
not in any real danger of violating the
statute of secrecy now we aren't saying
that a muggle wouldn't be smart enough
to create such a detailed magical world
but we would much prefer it if Hogwarts
and all the other magical places were
real Rita Skeeter has been pretty
skilled at writing fiction her whole
career even though she was supposed to
be writing facts Harry and the Dementors
Dementors are one of the creepiest
creatures in the Harry Potter books
these dark faceless creatures literally
suck out all of the happiness in your
soul that's pretty much the worst spate
ever in the books Harry is extra
affected by the Dementors he hears
screaming and passes out
Dementors make everyone feel pretty
miserable but why is Harry so affected
by their presence
he even passes out when he is way up on
his broom stick and the Dementors are on
the ground supposedly it's because Harry
free lives the night his parents spell -
Valda mourns but Harry isn't the only
wizard to experience horrible tragedy
why doesn't everyone who has seen awful
things react as Harry does also Harry
was just over a year old when his
parents were killed if there's been a
theory going around for years about this
it's not that Harry has a terrible
memory when the Dementors are around is
because he is a Horcrux the Dementors
are drawn to Harry because they can
sense that he has an extra soul inside
of him and the memory he relives is
actually Baltimore it's worst memory so
when the Dementors are around there are
two souls inside of Harry reacting to
them we wonder if Harry had an easier
time around Dementors after the Horcrux
inside him was defeated diagonally the
sorting hat secret you know how it
happens the first years are taken to
Hogwarts by small boats across the Black
Lake they are ushered into the Great
Hall where they see a raggedy old hat
sitting on a stool the Hat starts to
sing it spends all year creating a new
song about Hogwarts and its founders
then one by one each student is called
up to sit on the stool the sorting hat
reads their minds and decide which house
they belong in we know Ron doesn't know
how the
sorting will happen but he has had five
siblings go to Hogwarts before him in
fact most of the students have family
members who went to Hogwarts why are
they all shocked by the sorting hat this
plot hole was pointed out by ben karlin
from the super Karl in brothers how is
such a huge secret kept from all these
young witches and wizards the only
logical explanation is that the sorting
hat is under a fidelia's charm if you
remember in the order of the Phoenix
this is the charm that requires a secret
keeper only the secret keeper can reveal
the truth to people who don't know it
but once you are in on the secret you
can talk about it to others who know
number 12 Grimmauld place is under the
fidelia's charm and Dumbledore is the
secret keeper harry's childhood home was
also under the fidelia's charm Peter
Pettigrew was the secret keeper and he
told Baltimore where it was so who is
the Hatt's secret keeper
it's either McGonigle who leads the
sorting ceremony or it's the Hat itself
what happened to the grinders one of the
saddest moments in the Deathly Hallows
is when we learn about Hermione's major
sacrifice to save her parents hermione
knows at baltimore to end the Death
Eaters are going after muggle-borns and
their families
she obliviate sure parents removing all
memories of their only daughter she
convinces them that they are other
people who have always wanted to go to
Australia in the movie Deathly Hallows
Part 1 we actually see her mind he cast
the charm but in the books she just
tells Harry what she has done
tumblr users savers thinks that she
actually performs the memory charm of
much sooner in fact they think she did
it as early as their fourth year
hermione knows that Voldemort is gaining
power because she's friends with Harry
at the Quidditch World Cup she sees
exactly how Death Eaters treat muggles
she would be really worried about her
parents during this time she is smart
she knows another war is coming after
her fourth year she never goes home
again
she always spends her summers at the
Weasleys also when she has Madame
Pomfrey shrinker teeth back to a normal
size she doesn't even worry about what
her dentist parents will say their
buck-toothed child is magically not
buck-toothed anymore that's because her
parents are long gone as just a young
teenager hermione sacrificed having
loving parents to keep them alive no
under Hermione was sorted into
Gryffindor instead of Ravenclaw do you
know any epic Harry Potter theories let
us know in the comments we hope you
don't have to make a trip to st. Mungo's
Hospital for magical maladies after
these mind-blowing theories for more
awesome videos be sure to subscribe